Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P You're welcome to
call any time. Our anti-vaccine friend, I guess,
Erik from Mass called in and he really assails my
character in a horrible way, claiming that
I'm happy that Dymond died. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. It's Klamath. Yeah.
Diamond. The diamond silk done the. You root for
all your political opponents to die from Cobell.
Speaker 1: I have never rooted for anyone
to die of COVID.
Speaker 2: And Trump
should be arrested just because people
have different thoughts than you do.
Speaker 1: I have never, ever said Trump should
be arrested for any reason other than it appears
he committed crimes somehow.
Speaker 2: Believable. I mean,
I don't know where you get off on this.
I'd like you to do one thing. Do a video on
any crime that Trump committed. But you can't
because you can't find one that is doing anything.
But you must be happy for you, buddy.
Speaker 1: We have done extensive
videos on that. We talked and again, the
framing a crime that Trump committed.
People are innocent until proven guilty. So
if I went on the air and said Trump should be
convicted of X crime, people would rightly write
to me and say, Well, but David, you're innocent
until proven guilty. He's got to be charged then.
Then you need a trial. But of course, there is
significant evidence that Trump was criminally
involved in the incitement of the riots and that
Trump's actions trying to overturn the results
in Georgia, even though Joe Biden won so that
those votes would be those electoral votes would
be given to Trump was also an extorted fraud.
It is not up to me to determine that, though It
is up for it is up to the judicial system. And
we will hopefully soon learn more about that.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Katie Porter is running for Senate. I think she's
great. We're going to talk about it. Number two,
John Bolton now says he will run in 2024 if
it's what's necessary to prevent Donald Trump
from being president again. Interesting
guy that Bolton, not a huge fan of his,
I have to tell you. And Americans are piling up
credit card debt at record rates and it could
prove very costly to the economy as well as to
people's personal finances. We will talk about all
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money. Yeah. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: In addition to that, tonight at 6 p.m.
Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific, we will have our first
David Pakman Show Town Hall of 2023. I really
want you to be there. We will be streaming it
live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. We will
also be welcoming your call you it's really you
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Discord is how we take the calls.
I look forward to speaking with you. You can also
just watch even if you don't have a question for
me. But it's going to be great and we will
see you then. Otherwise, back here tomorrow.